ah
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález llevamos poco
más de un mes de haber comenzado el 2022
y méxico ya ha visto como cuatro
periodistas perdieron la vida ejerciendo
su labor informativa en lo poco que va
corrido de este año ya fueron asesinados
josé luís gamboa en la ciudad de
veracruz el pasado 10 de enero
margarito martínez murió en tijuana el
17 de enero lourdes maldonado también
fue asesinada en tijuana el 23 de enero
y roberto toledo falleció en zitácuaro
el 31 de enero
según cifras publicadas por diferentes
medios mexicanos el país suma ya 148
periodistas asesinados por su labor
desde el año 2000 hasta la fecha 53 de
ellos solamente durante el mandato del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
quien gobierna mexico desde diciembre
del 2018 las agresiones hacia los
periodistas son diarias y la impunidad
es prácticamente total poco o nada
avanzan las investigaciones de los casos
lo que lleva a facilitar que se perpetúe
esta violencia contra los periodistas en
ese país
lópez obrador critica constantemente a
los medios de comunicación y este a su
vez es señalado por la sociedad mexicana
y por los propios medios por no adoptar
medidas de protección a los
comunicadores aunque después de varias
críticas y de algunas manifestaciones en
las calles se refirió a este tema
escuchemos
el proceso de revisión de estos
mecanismos
para la protección de periodistas y de
luchadores sociales
está a cargo de alejandro encinas
subsecretario de gobernación y se va a
buscar también
y acuerdos con los gobiernos estatales
para profundizar
en este tema tan importante
el de edad la protección
a periodistas
y estamos trabajando en eso
estoy seguro que vamos a
para lograr mejorar
todo lo que es la protección a los
periodistas
las preocupantes cifras de asesinatos
han llevado a que la organización
reporteros sin fronteras calificar a
méxico como el más mortífero para la
prensa en el mundo incluso por encima de
países en donde no hay conflictos o
guerras porque la violencia se ensañó
con los comunicadores mexicanos porque
el gobierno no actúa donde queda la
justicia que pueden hacer los
comunicadores y la sociedad mexicana que
es importante en todo este rompecabezas
para poder cambiar este panorama hoy en
el debate de france 24 la prensa
mexicana bajo la mira y en peligro para
analizar este tema saludamos a marta
ramo sos a ella es presidenta ejecutiva
de alianza de medios mx ella se
encuentra en la capital mexicana y
también allí en ciudad de méxico se
conecta a esta conversación ya albert
woods en ojos en representante en méxico
del comité para la protección de
periodistas ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con todos sus comentarios
y todas sus preguntas las pueden hacer a
través de las redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram y en
twitter ya les recuerdo que estamos como
sant y luego que es mi cuenta personal y
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios y
preguntas relacionadas con este tema
comienzo entonces con marta ramos
nuestra primera invitada gracias marta
por estar con nosotros en el programa
hoy desde ciudad de méxico
qué es lo que sucede en méxico porque
ejercer el periodismo allí se convirtió
en una actividad tan peligrosa donde los
periodistas como yo decía están bajo la
mira y el peligro constante cuáles son
los sectores que se están articulando
que están generando estas amenazas a los
medios de comunicación y a los
periodistas
muchas gracias por la invitación y
gracias por tener interés en este tema
yo creo que es multifactorial estábamos
justamente en la alianza tuvimos una
reunión temprano hoy para analizar el
problema para analizar qué está pasando
con estos ataques porque si bien son
cuatro los que han sido asesinados en lo
que va del año hay dos ataques más donde
afortunadamente este no hubo
consecuencias fatales una noche en
cancún y otro hace una semana en oaxaca
y se juntan un montón de cosas pero yo
creo que la principal ahorita es la
descomposición propia del país porque
casi todos los factores
yo diría quizá con con
con la excepción de lourdes maldonado
que habría que investigar con más
cuidado casi en todos los demás casos
tiene que ver con una descomposición de
la región producto de
de un crecimiento del poder del crimen
organizado y por otro lado de una falta
de control del estado en todos sus
niveles para poder frenar esta violencia
y michoacán oaxaca son un ejemplo claro
veracruz por supuesto y baja california
que había bajado mucho parece que está
subiendo también y hay también un
discurso oficial desde presidencia que
no ayuda y que nos pone en creo yo en un
en un panorama mucho más frágil a la
hora de ejercer nuestra profesión
el propio instituto roiter se ha dado
cuenta de ello este donde se daña la
confianza hacia los medios de
comunicación y lo que tú muy bien decías
en un principio una impunidad de más de
90 por ciento en los casos contra
periodistas pues tampoco ayuda lo que en
realidad hemos tratado de hacer es
presionar para que las investigaciones
en cada uno de estos casos lleguen hasta
saber al menos cuál era el móvil detrás
de cada uno de los casos y saber de qué
qué tan grave es el tema contra la
libertad de expresión no lo sabemos no
podemos tener un diagnóstico claro con
una impunidad a ese nivel no le pregunto
también a jan al verte en la ciudad de
mexico en la capital mexicana sobre su
opinión para el punto de partida de este
debate porque ejercerá y el periodismo
es tan complicado marta nos hablaba como
de esta articulación que hay entre lo
político y el crimen organizado
múltiples factores cuál es su punto de
vista
pues yo coincido con marta en su
análisis yo creo que uno de los
problemas principales en méxico que
actualmente enfrentan los periodistas
acá es la impunidad en realidad en la
gran mayoría de los casos de asesinatos
de periodistas pero también
desapariciones porque según cifras del
propio cgpj organización que yo
represento en méxico cuenta con el mayor
número de periodistas desaparecidos a
nivel mundial pues en la gran mayoría de
esos casos no hay ninguna detención no
hay ninguna sentencia no hay ningún
acceso a la justicia para las familias y
para los colegas de los periodistas
victimizados ahí no hay acceso a la
verdad y en a lo largo de los seis años
que yo llevo representando el cgpj en
mexico
me he podido enterar de que la gran
mayoría de las investigaciones la
impunidad reina no porque simplemente es
imposible averiguar que está pasando
sino por inacción por omisión por falta
de voluntad por parte de las diferentes
autoridades en méxico o en el peor de
los casos por colusión o involucramiento
de la propia autoridad en el crimen
contra los periodistas
diciéndolo de forma muy sencilla si tú
en méxico eres una persona que se ve
afectada a sus intereses por una
conjetura periodística si tienes la
capacidad y la voluntad de cometer actos
de extrema violencia contra una un
periodista no hay en realidad nada que
te detiene porque sabes muy bien que la
posibilidad de que salgas con lo tuyo es
muy grande y eso es el problema
principal que es producto de años
décadas de negligencia por parte de los
diferentes niveles de gobierno en méxico
y como también ya señaló marca pues una
actitud
en la mejor de los escenarios
indiferentes o en la peor los escenarios
hostil del propio residente la república
y su gobierno federal hacia la prensa en
méxico en este momento a ver varios
factores para analizar entonces
partiendo de esta primera intervención
de ustedes dos hablan de impunidad
hablan de inacción por parte de las
autoridades
quiero que comencemos a desglosar ya ser
muy puntuales con las intervenciones
para poder abarcar la mayor cantidad de
temas posibles comencemos con la
impunidad aquí entonces el tema es al
interior de las instituciones de
justicia y de investigación que también
se han visto
afectadas por la corrupción estatal por
la corrupción de los grupos
delincuenciales o porque simplemente los
mecanismos de acción no engranan y no
avanzan cuál es su opinión marta
yo creo que hay mucho de colusión en los
diferentes niveles quizá y por eso
siempre vemos que la mayoría de los
ataques contra periodistas son en zonas
o sea no son en la capital del país son
en zonas alejadas son por ejemplo el
ataque contra el compañero de waha que
es en la zona mi en la zona mixteca que
tiene poco de ser o sea que está lejos
de ser una gran ciudad no porque son
donde hay más colusión y donde está más
debilitado el sistema de justicia no el
sistema de justicia municipal puede que
haya conoció pero también están igual de
desprotegidos que nosotros es decir ahí
siempre se enfrentan con un crimen que
está mucho mejor armado mucho mejor
organizado y que tiene este mucho
mejores armas para salir adelante que
ellos mismos entonces estamos entre este
panorama que que no tenemos una fuerza
de protección
sólida y este otro panorama de
presunta colusión que yo creo que es
bastante grande donde porque habría
algún interés de investigar nada si
ellos mismos están también metidos esto
esto nosotros lo ubicamos desde los
ochentas con picos no de acuerdo a cómo
ha sido la relación con con las
diferentes bandas del crimen organizado
creemos que ahorita se ha se ha agravado
bastante desde mediados del año pasado
hasta ahora las cifras marta ya no
quiero que con usted analizar el tema de
la inacción del estado porque muchos de
estos asesinatos y crímenes están
relacionados con periodistas que han
estado investigando casos de corrupción
por parte de funcionarios del gobierno
tráfico de drogas o
de personas también allí en la zona de
frontera
y que envuelven a diferentes
funcionarios estatales de todo nivel no
solamente de los estados mexicanos sino
también del gobierno federal esto sería
entonces la causa principal de esta
inacción por parte de las autoridades
por parte del gobierno federal porque
simplemente quiere esconder que varios
de sus funcionarios pueden estar siendo
partícipes de actos delictivos
claro yo creo que hay muchos casos que
nosotros también la alianza de medios y
muchas otras organizaciones la sociedad
civil hemos documentado
en los cuales vemos que hay siempre
reportes de amenazas por parte de por
ejemplo policías municipales que luego
según los propios reporteros
involucrados se ven están involucrados
en por ejemplo
tiroteos en el narcotráfico en trata de
personas como como bien comienzas yo
creo que es una parte muy importante
obviamente la policía no va a investigar
algo que podría poner en peligro sus
propios intereses si esos intereses se
derivan de una corrupción y una
corrupción de la cooperación policiaca
pero también hay otro otro tema muy
importante cuando estamos hablando de la
omisión o la inacción y me gustaría dar
dos ejemplos muy recientes que tienen
que ver con dos de los cuatro casos de
homicidios que hemos visto este año
el primero fue que cuando en la ciudad
de tijuana asesinaron a margarito
martínez las primeras notas que salieron
de ahí
mencionaron que lo que le provocó la
muerte era una especie de pleito o una
altercación entre vecinos que había
alcohol en juego
etcétera y según los medios que hoy con
quienes yo he conversado
cuando estuve en tijuana la semana
pasada para justamente investigar un
poco más lo que había pasado la fuente
de esa versión
fue la policía municipal que había
llegado al lugar
curiosamente no hay absolutamente nadie
en el lugar donde mataron a margarito
que me pudo decir si había un altercado
es más según todos los vecinos con
quienes yo he platicado no había ningún
altercado más bien no había nadie en la
calle y la fiscalía la propia fiscalía
de baja california inmediatamente
descartó esa versión entonces ahí vemos
qué
la autoridad municipal de tijuana
aparentemente tiene un interés en que
desde inicios se deslinda completamente
la los hechos de la labor periodística
de margarito martínez el segundo muy
bien el segundo caso fue lo que pasó el
lunes de esta semana cuando asesinaron a
roberto de un lado un colaborador de
medios enfatizó no nosotros no lo
tenemos identificado tanto como
periodista sino como colaborador de
medios según la versión del propio
director del medio en el que laboraba
monitores bacán y cuando fue asesinado
en casi inmediatamente el vocero de la
presidencia de la república jesús
ramírez cuevas manuel tweet diciendo que
según investigaciones judiciales no se
trataba de un periodista sino de una
auxiliar de un despacho de abogados esta
versión fue bastante como diré
lamentable porque el propio medio ya
había confirmado que el regato toledo
era
y colaboradores se me dio la parte local
20 de presidentes se le fue
aparentemente pueblo que no ha parado en
las investigaciones judiciales que cita
es que el abogado que trabaja en ese
despacho también el subdirector del
medio monitor michoacán y claro o sea
eso no es una coincidencia de la razón
porque en el propio gobierno federal
inmediatamente trata de desligar
servetto toleró de la volpe periodística
es porque no les conviene mucho tenía
que explicar por qué hay cuatro
asesinatos de periodistas en menos de un
mes
y ahí ahí es donde vemos esa inacción
esa falta de voluntad de investigar si
pero ellos intentarán desligarse pero
siempre hay medios como éste en este
caso que quiere profundizar y analizar
la situación porque no es normal que
cuatro periodistas pierdan la vida en
solamente cuatro semanas y que 53
periodistas hayan perdido la vida hayan
sido asesinados desde el inicio del
gobierno de andrés manuel lópez obrador
porque si todo esto porque quiero llegar
a ese punto esa es la relación que tiene
el gobierno del presidente de lópez
obrador con los medios de comunicación
varias veces lo hemos visto en su
conferencia de prensa conocida como la
mañanera atacando los medios atacando a
los periodistas criticando los y la
relación no ha sido buena ha sido un
tire y afloje a lo largo de estos años y
ustedes que están allí en las fronteras
mexicanas nosotros estamos por fuera es
poco lo que podemos ver pero cómo es la
relación entre el gobierno federal y los
medios es simplemente un tire y afloje o
como lo describiría usted marta
yo creo que tiene dos niveles por
supuesto es la que la relación que
tenemos en el trabajo diario
acercándonos a funcionarios buscando
investigando entrevistando y la otra es
esta pública que se ve todos los días en
esta conferencia queda en las mañanas
donde incluso a todos los miércoles
dedica un buen espacio con una persona
en específico a desmentir noticias en un
ejercicio muy desafortunado que no
alcanza ni siquiera a poder documentar
lo que está diciendo pero que para la
opinión pública tiene un efecto
totalmente contrario y que pretende
debilitar a los medios de comunicación
como una fuente fidedigna de información
por otro lado uno ve que en su trabajo
diario pues él necesita como todo el
mundo necesitamos saber de que estar
informado saber cómo pasar la
información que se está dando a conocer
no esto entonces yo creo que que la la
pública la que le interesa y yo creo que
el presidente es muy bueno para eso lo
demostró en campañas y todo eso en la
pública
que está afectando mucho está esta
debilidad del trabajo periodístico en
todo el país
la otra fluye como ha fluido toda la
vida porque vamos trabajando juntos para
una misma misma pública mismo país pero
está pública que le está haciendo es
totalmente distinta este discurso que tú
pasaste sobre su interés por mejorar el
mecanismo de protección y eso lo dijo
hace tres años y no ha habido más que
recortes de presupuestos
claro ya le pregunto por esa
indiferencia por parte de el presidente
es diciente es como calificar
simplemente esta falta de interés por
este tipo de asesinatos este tipo de
hechos que le cuesta grandes críticas a
méxico a nivel internacional el país no
queda bien parado ante la comunidad
internacional por el manejo de los
medios y el manejo de la información y
esta relación difícil que tiene él con
los comunicadores que se puede decir de
esa indiferencia
a mí se me hace muy llamativo
el propio presidente de la república
está invirtiendo cada día o cada semana
recursos públicos en una parte de su
conferencia mañana ir a la conferencia
de prensa diaria que él da para decir
quién es quién en mentiras de la prensa
y son recursos públicos que no sirven
para nada al final más allá de polarizar
generar divisiones mientras como bien
señala marca no ha habido ninguna
política pública siria durante los
últimos tres años no ha habido una
inversión sustancial de recursos en
instituciones dedicadas a la protección
de periodistas
y eso creo que es muy grave pero yo creo
que lo peor de todo de todo esto es que
si se está hablando del mecanismo bueno
ahora la secretaria y la combinación
está
intentando generar una propuesta
legislativa para reformarlo nosotros
también estamos participando en los
foros sobre esa posible reforma pero lo
que en realidad no se escucha es que va
a ser el presidente que va a ser este
gobierno para combatir la impunidad
si establecimos que
la impunidad es el factor que más
incentiva toda la violencia contra
defensores de derechos humanos y
periodistas cómo es que el propio
presidente nunca habla de este tema cómo
es que hace recortes brutales en todos
los que de todas las instituciones que
deben tener más recursos y mejor
capacitación su personal para combatir
la impunidad de nada va a servir el
mejor mecanismo del mundo con el mayor
presupuesto en el mundo y el personal
más calificado más capacitado del mundo
si la causa principal de la violencia
que es la impunidad que es la falta de
investigaciones policiacas que es la
falta de capacidad de voluntad de los
fiscales se ha mejorado tiene que tener
esa problemática yo creo que la
indiferencia del presidente se nota en
la cantidad de recursos y energía que él
invierte en polarizar en atacar
herramientas y medios
la absoluta ausencia de energía y
recursos que invierten en políticas
públicas relevantes pero vamos a ver
aquí cómo empiezan a moverse las fichas
jan y marta porque el caso de lourdes
maldonado es tal vez el más terrorífico
de los cuatro que hemos visto a lo largo
de este mes porque precisamente ella
viajó desde tijuana esta ciudad de
méxico estaba presente en la conferencia
de prensa del presidente y aparte de
hacerle algunas preguntas le comentó su
situación le dijo que estaba en peligro
le comentó cuáles eran sus inquietudes y
el presidente matizó la situación se lo
dejo a su jefe de prensa y del caso no
se volvió a hablar y una semana después
lourdes apareció asesinada en la ciudad
de tijuana este caso por esta escena
propia allí en en la conferencia de
prensa toca directamente al presidente y
también porque las acusaciones que hacía
lourdes y el caso que estaba ella
adelantando de un caso de corrupción de
un funcionario que es parte de esa
coalición de gobierno de la que
pertenece a la que pertenece el
presidente que se llama morena lo acusa
no haber dicho en su declaración de
renta que tenía unas propiedades en eeuu
y algunos en algunos casos de evasión de
impuestos todo esto está bajo
investigación no estamos acusando a
nadie lo estamos mencionando nada más
pero esto sin duda alguna ya toca el
presidente muy cerca es un caso muy
cercano un funcionario
acusado y la periodista que investigaba
asesinada con el paso de solamente unos
días después de haber estado frente a
frente con el presidente marta fueron a
la denuncia que ella hizo frente al
presidente tenía más tiempo lo que sí
tenía unos días es que ella dijo que ya
había ganado el juicio laboral contra
este personaje que tú dices quién fue el
gobernador del estado de baja california
del mismo partido político que el
presidente llamar la atención que en esa
conferencia de prensa el presidente fue
extremadamente veloz en deslindar a su a
su compañero de partido al ex gobernador
de cualquier vínculo con el asesinato de
lourdes esto aún sin haber ninguna
investigación jurídica al respecto creo
que en el caso específico del por la
presión mediática si habrá una
investigación mucho más seria eso
esperamos no pero ciertamente fue lo
primero que hizo el presidente fue
deslindar al funcionario de cualquier
vínculo con el asesinato de lourdes si
es también terrible porque a lourdes
todo lo conocemos de hace muchos años ha
trabajado para todos nosotros para
televisa para el sol de tijuana porque
ella tiene una trayectoria de larguísima
por eso dolió tanto jan por más que el
presidente haya querido desligar a su
compañero de equipo a este ex gobernador
de apellido bonilla
si la investigación progresa y si
digamos como dice marta la presión lleva
que de verdad comienza una investigación
seriamente esto necesariamente tiene que
involucrar a este a este personaje
político muy cercano al presidente tiene
que pasar por ese para por esa parte
usted cree que puede empezar a desviarse
la investigación por otros caminos
simplemente para desviar la atención
pero debemos empezar con la evidencia
que tenemos
en este momento pues no se ha publicado
ni filtrado alguna información que
podría vincular a la expo grado jaime
bonilla de baja california con esos
asesinatos y el creo que eso debe ser
muy claro y yo también creo que las
razones por las que lourdes maldonado se
sentía amenazada por lo menos en sus
propias palabras todos tenían que ver
con el mismo personaje entonces yo creo
que es importante que la autoridad en
baja california o la autoridad federal
si ellos deciden atraer caso lo dudo
mucho porque no lo ha hecho en muchos de
esos casos pero podría ser pues que
vayan viendo cada línea de investigación
y otra cosa que todavía no hemos
mencionado en el caso de algunos que
creo que también es importante en
youtube la oportunidad de visitarla a la
residencia del domicilio de lourdes
maldonado la semana pasada con los
findes visita a tijuana y ahí noté cómo
varias evidencias
del supuesto esquema de protección que
ella había recibido de la autoridad del
estado de baja california incluyendo un
sistema de cámara vigilancia rondines
policíacos etcétera
según la información que nosotros hemos
podido
juntar hayan tijuana no ha habido
absolutamente nada que hubiera
evitado ese ataque porque no ha habido
no hubo presencia policiaca
aparentemente no lo hubo como realmente
muchas imágenes de vídeo ojalá que el
gobierno de la autoridad de baja
california lo puede aclarar porque ya
van aproximadamente 10 periodistas en un
sistema de un programa de seguridad
estatal o federal que ha sido asesinados
en los últimos años y esta parte también
se tiene que investigar quién ha sido
omisa quien ha sido responsable claro
quiénes son los culpables de este crimen
hay un componente que importante que no
hemos tocado ya hemos hablado de las
fallas las fallas del sistema
y la particularidad que tiene méxico por
tener diferentes bandas de crimen
organizado y de carteles pero hay un
componente importante y es la sociedad
mexicana que tanto juegan aquí la
sociedad mexicana también se muestran
indiferentes como el gobierno y el resto
de las autoridades tienen un poco más de
compromiso y son importantes para
resolver esta situación marta su opinión
yo creo que yo creo que ha habido
que nos hemos separado sociedad mexicana
y medios de comunicación en este tema
en otros años donde ha habido también un
número considerable de ataques contra
periodistas la sociedad mexicana había
sido mucho más activa en apoyar al
trabajo periodístico este año no lo
hemos visto tanto quizá todo sucedió
demasiado rápido como tú bien dices
apenas acaba de terminar el primer mes
del año estamos en unas circunstancias
singular que nos tiene la pan de mes de
hace dos años esto pero no no se ha
visto tanta vinculación de la sociedad
como en otros años es
triste creo yo debe haber varias
explicaciones para ello la polarización
que ya no estaba indicando muy bien es
un factor yo creo determinante ya ella
habla mart habla de la polarización como
uno de los de las posibles causas de
ésta
distanciamiento digámoslo así por parte
de la sociedad usted está de acuerdo con
este punto de vista creo que hay otros
factores necesarios para mencionar allí
que la sociedad mexicana esté lo
suficientemente preocupada e indignada
molesta por este tipo de asesinatos o no
conocido mucho con lo que comentó marta
y de hecho yo creo que
hay dos efectos muy muy lamentables de
la polarización generada por el
presidente de lópez obrador y otros
funcionarios de su gobierno y el primero
es que desvía la atención de la falta de
políticas públicas entonces
genera como más dificultades para la
opinión pública
en el debate público vea con claridad lo
que está haciendo bien con lo que está
haciendo mal al gobierno porque cada día
en las primeras dos horas del día el
presidente logra de forma muy exitosa lo
que políticamente es una muy buena
estrategia enfocar la tensión
completamente en la polarización la
segunda parte que creo todavía más
de experimental para la situación en
méxico es que el gobierno
de andrés manuel lópez obrador en virtud
de su personalidad de quién es
es un gobierno con muy altos índices de
popularidad todavía por personas que
exigen plenamente en lo que dice y lo
que hace el presidente y lo apoyan en
prácticamente todo lo que hace y lo que
dice entonces cuando el gobierno de
lópez obrador está constantemente
diciendo que los periodistas son
corruptos que las y los periodistas son
conservadores que van en contra de su
proyecto político que son enemigos del
estado etcétera etcétera y entonces cada
vez que ocurre un asesinato un hecho muy
muy violento para nosotros como
periodistas como sociedad civil es
bastante difícil convencer a la opinión
pública de que es un tema relevante el
mejor en general es lo que pasó el año
pasado cuando la compañera azucena
urestí recibió una amenaza por parte del
cártel jalisco nueva generación y que
aunque el presidente hubiera dicho de
que lo iba a ver que era inaceptable
había seguidores del mismo presidente
que redes sociales dijeron es que ella
es derechista conservadora
y seguro se lo merece y ahí vemos el
efecto de las palabras del presidente
efecto me quedo con esa palabra eso me
lleva a la siguiente pregunta marta y
jan pasando a la órbita netamente
informativa esto en el mediano plazo o
en el largo plazo cómo va a jugar en
cuanto al contenido informativo de los
medios mexicanos y que lleven de pronto
a que méxico se vuelva una sociedad
desinformada o mal informada que vaya en
detrimento de la calidad informativa que
tiene porque el miedo puede llevar a
simplemente alejarse de esferas de
investigación o de temas simplemente
para salvar la vida como lo ve usted
marta ya sucede es decir hay zonas
absolutamente silenciadas en el país la
sierra de guerrero todo el estado de
tamaulipas parte de jalisco en los
últimos dos años creo que partes del
centro del país guanajuato zacatecas ya
sucede es decir nosotros podemos tener
información que nos mandan reporteros
desde esa zona
y vamos siguiendo protocolos que hemos
ido aprendiendo con el tiempo esa
información no sale firmada no mucha
información es solo a partir de fuentes
oficiales para no ponernos en riesgo no
sabemos este si si nos ponemos en medio
de la discusión entre entre dos bandas
no
y hay zonas donde definitivamente no
entramos claro en el caso específico de
roberto toledo asesinado en michoacán lo
digo abiertamente decidimos no ir al
sepelio como muchos decidieron no ir al
sepelio por la zona donde es el caso de
personas desaparecidas hacia el norte de
tamaulipas son los propios familiares de
esas personas desaparecidas que
negociaron con el crimen organizado para
convencer entonces a la policía que las
acompañará a una zona donde iban a
buscar restos a ver si encontraran a sus
familiares bajo esas condiciones tan
extrañas fue que los medios decidimos
acompañarlas bajo otras condiciones los
medios no se para a la desazón
este fenómeno ya sucede desde la sucede
me quedan 30 segundos para su conclusión
y su cierre sobre este tema rápidamente
por si muchas gracias sí estoy muy de
acuerdo con mate yo creo que se está
generando en méxico son las de silencio
con autocensura con ya no hay periodismo
significativo y usted se puede imaginar
qué va a pasar cuando hay una elección
con candidatos acusados de corrupción en
periodismo que los investigue por el
peligro que corren esto es el efecto que
queremos en la sociedad mexicana pues a
marta ramos ya hayan albert woods en el
disculpar a yann mineur landés les
agradezco por haber acompañado a la
audiencia de france 24 la explicación de
este tema ponernos en contexto de lo que
está sucediendo allí en mexico ya los
colegas periodistas mexicanos también
todas nuestras fuerzas y acá estamos con
ustedes en su labor informativa del día
a día seguiremos muy de cerca los hechos
que vayan ocurriendo allí en este país
ustedes pueden seguir entonces con la
programación de france 24 sigan con
nosotros
[Música]